13:27 nous sommes de retour à la maison dites-lui que vous avez
un colis ici Tokyo Tokyo
comment j'essaie de me convertir à un
turbocompresseur nous ne sommes pas venus depuis
la fin vu en mille bières six plus
vous êtes ici  en 2012 père merci pour
le rassemblement d'amis oui la famille
tous ensemble famille tous ensemble c'était
12 ans après que nous ayons filmé la même
scène en 2000
je suppose que c'est rare de faire un film et de
retourner réellement à l'endroit authentique et
original c'est  un
endroit spécial à la fois pour la saga et pour nous, une
grande partie de nos carrières a commencé dans cette
maison en parlant pour moi-même la première fois que
j'étais ici je n'avais aucune idée de ce qui se
passait j'étais un petit bébé qui courait partout
mais chaque fois que nous sommes ici  on a juste l'impression
que la relation continue d'évoluer et de
grandir et évidemment nous avons traversé
tellement de choses à la fois à l'écran et à l'
extérieur c'était juste dans la cuisine et je
me suis souvenu oh c'était la scène que je
n'ai pas suivie en lavant la vaisselle
je vois le cuisinier  ne nettoie pas quand je viens
de  ouais j'aimerais y aller comme à
chaque coin de rue que tu tournes dans cette maison tu te
souviens d'une autre scène qui est si vraie je
sais que pour moi c'était très utile très
important que ma sœur termine
ce film quelqu'un qui a été comme une
sœur dans laquelle je suis tous les deux  la vraie vie et et dans
ces rôles auxquels nous nous sommes engagés
il y a 14 ans et sans
jamais regarder en arrière, vous le verrez vous
allez le voir dans le film vous pourrez en être
témoin de première main cette
essence familiale que seul Fast and Furious
apporte  c'est pourquoi vous avez tous été si
favorables et c'est pourquoi vous
nous avez encouragés à continuer au-delà
des attentes des gens